David Bose author of libertarianism and
the libertarian reader can you remember
the first moment you thought that's what
you'd call yourself politically I'm not
sure I remember it exactly it was
probably when I was a high school senior
and I probably read on Rand and started
thinking of myself that way might have
been when I was in college when I really
thought what these ideas amount to that
I'm developing here is libertarianism
why iron Rand well a lot of people
retain Rand
when they're young I was interested in
politics my father was involved in
politics and so he got me thinking about
it actually I think the first political
book I read might have been the
conscience of a conservative by Barry
Goldwater and then I read economics in
one lesson by Henry Hazlitt which is
just a brilliant discussion in a hundred
pages or so of what economics is what it
means to think like an economist and
that got me thinking in that direction
and then when I was a senior I Rand
wrote great novels I mean whether you
were into politics or not they were fun
to read and I pulled one off the shelf
and I ended up reading it all through
spring break and that really kind of
made me think about what I thought the
nature of freedom was and what
individual rights were supposed to be
and that put me on the course I think
which one of her novels did you like the
best well it's hard to say I think Atlas
Shrugged is probably the most
comprehensive one she thought was the
fullest presentation of her ideas but a
lot of people think we the living is a
more more of a real novel the characters
are less political it's more realistic
it's probably the one that was most
autobiographical but if you kind of want
the political message that Iran is
putting out then I think Atlas Shrugged
is the best tucked in the libertarian
reader is a name associated with iron
Rand Alan Greenspan Alan Greenspan where
were they ever together well Alan
Greenspan became very close to mine Rand
when he was a young man in New York was
a great admirer of her philosophy and
personally close to her and contributed
one or more essays I think to one of the
books that she edited there were mostly
her essays and some other people
and I assume that he still maintains
that admiration did you ever meet her I
did not know this got two books for
signing we've ever done two books once
called the libertarian reader what's
this that's a collection of really I
think the first time this has been done
a collection of all the greatest
libertarian writings ever I generally
say from John Locke to Milton Friedman
but in fact there are a few below before
john locke including an excerpt from the
bible it's one of the first indications
of libertarian thought and it does go
right up to Milton Friedman and people
younger than he is Richard Epstein and
some of my colleagues at the Cato
Institute all the greatest writings on
libertarianism ever and what's this
libertarianism a primer is an
introduction to the ideas the history of
libertarianism of the way libertarianism
approaches the relationship of the
individual in the state and also the way
it approaches contemporary issues it's
all written by me the other one is all
written by people at much greater
stature
once the Cato Institute Cato Institute
is a public policy research organization
that sometimes abbreviated to think-tank
we're in Washington we'll be celebrating
our 20th anniversary this spring and it
is devoted to the ideas of individual
liberty free markets limited government
and peace where'd you get to name Cato
well that's a complicated story the
Institute is named potatoes letters
which were a series of pamphlets
published in the 18th century that were
very popular with the people who made
the American Revolution they were
published in England but they were
classical liberal which his ideas we
would now call libertarian essays on
contemporary issues the reason we picked
that name is that we perceived that the
authors of Cato's letters were taking
the ideas of philosophers like John
Locke and applying them to the issues of
the day that's what the Cato Institute
does we take the ideas of people like
John Locke and Adam Smith and Friedrich
Hayek and apply them to issues of the
day how big is the kick of Institute we
have a budget of about 8 million dollars
we have 50 staff members we have maybe
60 scholars around the country and even
a few around the world that we work with
as adjunct scholars
we publish 10 books a year 30 studies a
year now I remember talking to Adam
Bello who is the eternal director of the
Free Press that published this why did
you go to him to do this instead of
publishing the books yourself well I
think that the Free Press
being a part of Simon & Schuster has
great reach they can reach bookstores
they reach reviewers they can distribute
books better than the Cato Institute can
and after all I'm the senior editor at
the Cato Institute's if I'd been editing
my own book I'm sure it wouldn't have
come out as well I got some good
editorial help from the Free Press when
did you get the idea that you wanted
these two volumes to come out how long
ago about a year and a half ago it was
actually a pretty quick schedule the
Free Press was very good about turning
books around much quicker after the
manuscript was done than usually happens
it was I would say in 95 that I really
got interested in writing a book if I if
I'd done it my way it probably would
have been more of a manifesto and less
of a primer it was free presses idea
that a primer was what was really needed
that people would like to read an
introduction that was not just sort of
my opinion about the issues of the day
but that does introduce a tradition that
goes back really to the Bible and
Antigone right on through the
Renaissance the Levellers John Locke
Adam Smith the American Revolution up to
the present day so there's sort of a
chapter of history and then the ideas of
those people are woven throughout the
book on the cover of both books of
course is your name and the person to
see this for the first time would just
jump in there and say that's David Boaz
but you pronounce it Beau's how come
well I have no idea that's what my
father told me to pronounce it we are
eighth generation Scotch Irish Americans
and we claim that in Scotland we're
related to all the people who spell it
vo w es so maybe that's the reason that
200 years ago nobody could spell and
people when people learn to spell they
wrote it down different ways what town
were you born in Mayfield Kentucky it's
almost on the Mississippi River what was
your childhood like there oh pretty
standard Leave It to Beaver childhood I
guess actually I think Leave It to
Beaver was said in Mayfield although I
never assumed it was Kentucky my father
was a lawyer
my mother was a homemaker I have a
younger brother and sister we all went
to college pretty typical childhood what
kind of reading did you do early um I
did a lot of reading all sorts of things
I read a lot of novels one of my
earliest passions was astronomy when I
was about six seven years old and it was
the beginning of the space program and I
did a lot of that reading I'm sure I
know less about astronomy now than I did
when I was seven years old but at the
time it was very important to me when I
got to high school I was very interested
in politics and I read lots of big thick
political novels and then I got more
interested in political philosophy and I
started reading things like Henry
Hazlitt and Friedrich Hayek and and I
Rand Milton Friedman
can you point to anybody that got you
interested in that stuff well my father
certainly my father was very interested
in politics he was a politician he was a
judge in our local community and he was
very interested in political ideas and
he talked about the role of the
government he felt the federal
government was way too big and I guess
that got me thinking in that direction
and then as I started reading I found a
lot of evidence that I thought that was
true and and I now probably think it's a
it's it's a lot more too big than he
would have thought why I think probably
well for one thing it's gotten a lot
bigger and we can see more of the
problems than say we would have when my
father was my age but for another reason
I think I just perhaps read different
things thought about things differently
and decided that there was a more
fundamental indictment of the size of
government that there is something about
human beings that means they ought to be
free to live their lives the way they
want to and that intrusion by government
into that process is wrong and that came
to seem very consistent and very right
to me where'd you go to college
Vanderbilt University which is sort of
the closest big good school to Western
Kentucky Nashville right would you study
I started out studying political science
and then I decided that I wasn't very
impressed with what one studies in
political science to me they took a very
interesting subject and made it pretty
interesting so I ended up with a degree
in American history which i think is a
great background for doing anything
what'd you do after school I came to
Washington almost immediately I added to
the magazine called new guard which is
sort of a political magazine for young
people
group called the council for a
competitive economy and then it wasn't
very many years after college that I
ended up at the Cato Institute and I've
actually been there for 15 years
how old is Cato by the way 20 years in
the back of your ear primer you have a
little question-and-answer thing a
little little game that you can play to
find out if you're a libertarian or not
and you have two categories personal
freedom and economic freedom and it
might be interesting to just go down the
list of the questions you asked what was
the purpose of this by the way well I
it's really the publishers idea and I
think their view is that it's an
involvement device it's something you
might pick up on a shelf and decide to
look at and maybe that would cause you
to buy the book I'm a little
uncomfortable with it because I think
I've tried in the book to give a whole
sense of a tradition as I say running
back to the Greeks and the early
Israelites running through the
Renaissance the American Revolution
through great twentieth century thinkers
like Ludwig von Mises and Friedrich
Hayek and Milton Friedman and I think
it's awfully simplistic to try to sum it
up in 20 questions so you're not real
happy they're not my favorite part of
the book well in the first you say
you're supposed to take the quiz and you
apply give yourself ten points if you
think you decide that you just five
points of view you're not sure anyway
you say who should decide whether or not
you wear a seat belt own a gun serve in
the military smoke marijuana use a risky
medical treatment engage in a homosexual
relationship buy a pornographic video
buy a sexist book send your child to a
particular school have uncensored access
to the Internet
well each one of those I think does make
a libertarian point question is not
whether these are good things to do
there are a lot of the things on that
list that I don't want to do that I
wouldn't really want my friends to do
the question is who should make the
decision if you're an adult should you
make the decision whether to wear a
seatbelt or use an untested medical
treatment or should the government make
that decision for you and the
libertarian answer is that individuals
adult individuals should be able to make
those decisions for themselves what's
your favorite thing that's libertarian
the wonderful modern society we live in
society's libertarian sure it's not
quite as libertarian as I would like but
the modern world since the American
Revolution and since Adam Smith sort of
summed up the the notion of spontaneous
order in free markets the modern world
is built on the ideas of John Locke and
Adam Smith we do have a society in which
people are largely free to make their
own decisions in which free markets have
created tremendous prosperity I'm sure
you have people on your shows every day
complaining that some people are poor
that we can't get certain things that
Healthcare is not good enough if all
kinds of problems with the economy but
if you look at it in historical
perspective for tens of thousands of
years people were desperately poor they
suffered back-breaking labor and about
two hundred and fifty years ago we had
the Industrial Revolution we started
having free markets Karl Marx called it
capitalism because he thought capital
was the point but that's not the point
the point is people working freely
allowed to trade in exchange and they
created this tremendous wealth so that
we can sit here in this television
studio and you're going to film this and
be able to broadcast it nationally
internationally millions of people are
going to be able to watch this you put
some of this information on an internet
site and people can access at any time
of the day tremendous advances in
society in the economy and that's
because we've had a relatively
libertarian Society so I guess what I
like best about libertarianism is the
fact that I can live here at the end of
the 20th century and have unprecedented
access to ideas and music and goods and
travel and all those things that make
life really worth living legalize drugs
well that's another little aspect of it
yes I think that adults should be able
to make decisions about what they put in
their own body and it's interesting you
say legalize drugs you didn't say
whether you meant pharmaceutical or
recreational but I think the rule
applies either way if I wanted to use
marijuana or cocaine I don't think it's
Bill Clinton's decision whether I should
do that similarly if I have a disease
and my doctor recommends a drug but the
FDA hasn't approved it I think I should
be able to use it without a bureaucrats
permission same-sex marriages I think
that if the government is going to
recognize marriage then it should do so
on an equal basis and if two people love
each other to a dull
individuals then it is good for them to
be able to make a committed relationship
piece the word piece comes up in your
books here well I like these but what
about military and peace and all that
how does it need it we need a government
to protect our rights we need a
government to protect us from people who
might hurt us on our own streets that's
why we have police we have courts to
settle disputes and we need a National
Defense to protect us from people who
might hurt us overseas but if you look
at the history of the world there have
been so many instances of governments
getting into Wars to aggrandize
themselves to gain land to gain power it
used to be that that Kings would say I
did it to get better known
fortunately the the liberal libertarian
impulse in modern life has been so
strong that King can't say that anymore
but we still have too many countries
getting into unnecessary Wars sending
off kids to die exploiting the society
seizing money to be spent on military
expenditures we need a strong national
defense we need to be secure from our
enemies but in the present context I
don't think that means that we need
American boys in Somalia and Bosnia and
all the other places around the world
that our government seems to turn into
metal May and a half men and women under
or any uniform today in the United
States how big an army and maybe an Air
Force would you keep well that's a
Prudential thing I don't think it
follows directly from libertarian theory
or anything but my colleagues at the
Cato Institute who study military and
defense matters say that we would be
perfectly well protected with an army of
about a million people Army Navy Marine
Corps etc on page 279 of your primer you
say that most of our political leaders
are still living in Washington that
roosevelt built the washington where if
you think of a good idea you would
create a government program consider a
few examples and you start right off by
saying senator bob dole reads the first
amendment the template i'm sorry thank
you the tenth amendment and on the
campaign trail but introduces bills to
federalize criminal law welfare policy
and the definition of marriage
Bob Dole's not your candidate Bob Dole's
not my candidate I say I think that's a
problem with people who talk about the
Tenth Amendment there's a lot of talk
about the Tenth Amendment protecting the
rights of states and the people and
limiting the powers of the federal
government it absolutely does but
politicians who talk about that
nevertheless when a popular issue comes
up they pass a federal crime bill I
don't think there's any Authority in the
Constitution for the federal government
to be setting up most things as federal
crimes they pass a bill to make church
burning a federal crime church burning
is a terrible thing which is why it's
illegal in every one of the 50 states
you don't need a federal law about that
the second one is Vice President Gore
announces a plan to tear down public
housing saying these crime infested
monuments to a failed policy are killing
the neighborhoods around around them he
remind his listeners in the years past
Washington told people around the
country what to do dictating wisdom from
on high and let's be honest some of that
wisdom really wasn't very wise and then
he announces a plan to build new public
housing projects I think a lot of this
reinventing government initiative of the
Clinton administration shows a sort of
disconnect between understanding that
the current government structures have
failed and then basically rebuilding
them recapitulating them public housing
has failed so let's build more public
housing I think it's a real
unwillingness to face the fact that
coercive intervention in people's lives
doesn't work as well as markets do if we
had freer markets we'd have better
housing for the rich and for the poor
you know the way poor people get housing
in a capitalist economy generally is
they get used housing that rich people
built lived in for a while and pass it
on and that's not you know used clothes
maybe are getting a little threadbare
that's not usually true with used
housing you'll see ads in New York City
advertising pre-war construction and
what they're saying is those buildings
were built so well because they were
built for wealthy people but they're
still better today than a lot of newer
housing so let the free market work
you'd get better housing than the
Housing and Urban Development is going
to build is there any regular columnist
in any newspaper that is a libertarian
well it's difficult to say exactly what
a libertarian is a lot of times people
have libertarian attitudes on a lot of
things in America almost nobody is
Leon libertarian I think Steven Chapman
whose column appears in the Chicago
Tribune in The Washington Times and a
lot of other newspapers around the
country I'd call a libertarian and I'm
sure that there are a few others that
haven't sprung to mind right away is
there anybody in television that you
know that's either a reporter or a
commentator that's libertarian well in
general of course reporters don't want
to have political opinions and so I'm
not sure there may well be some of them
but but they try to keep it to
themselves as far as television
commentators I am Not sure that I think
of one right off I think there a lot of
radio talk-show hosts around the country
who are libertarians the most visible
well I think David Brad know in Boston
would admit to that I think Neal Boortz
in Atlanta probably would gene Burns who
I believe is now in San Francisco I
think those people put out a pretty
solid libertarian message from time to
time is there a place to go if you want
libertarian thought every week well if
you want libertarian thought every week
you could go to the Cato Institute
website every day
other than that Reason magazine is a
monthly Liberty magazine is a bi-monthly
those are probably the places that you'd
be most likely to get it although as I
say if you have a newspaper that has
Steven Chapman's column it's pretty
consistently libertarian who owns Reason
magazine it's owned by The Reason
Foundation which is a sort of competitor
in the Cato Institute another
libertarian oriented think-tank are
there different kinds of people involved
in their Reason Foundation that are
involved in the Cato foundation um not
exactly
The Reason Foundation a big part of what
they do is publish a monthly magazine
and so they have journalists involved
there and we don't really have
journalists at the Cato Institute also
The Reason Foundation has really
specialized in the issue of
privatization especially of state and
local services so they have a lot of
privatization experts and we don't
really have we don't do so much on that
issue we do more national issues so it's
a matter of emphasis and so on but not
really different kinds of people
what's the Liberty magazine Liberty
magazine is a bi-monthly it's a younger
magazine than reason been published for
a few years it's published out of
Washington State I think you might find
it a little more movement oriented more
for people who really are
self-consciously libertarians and think
of themselves that way
they want to read hard-hitting
libertarian analysis reason is more of a
current affairs magazine like the New
Republic but with the libertarian
perspective on issues and what about
Harry Brown the candidate for the
libertarian party did you support him
I'm an independent I don't really do
politics and of course at the Cato
Institute we're not supposed to get
involved in politics but to people at
the Cato Institute you know on their
primary point you heard around that you
know your organization's they like the
idea there's a libertarian party and
sometimes I carry Brown represent their
thoughts I think it's certainly fair to
say that Harry Brown was an articulate
exponent of ideas that most of the
people at Cato would also agree with
some people at Cato are Republicans
because they think that's the best place
to advance ideas of free markets in
civil society a few our Democrats
because they're more interested in
issues of civil liberties of peace some
are members of the Libertarian Party and
a lot of us as I say our independence we
find ourselves kept pretty busy putting
out books and studies and talking about
ideas without getting involved in
electoral politics and I think a lot of
libertarians these days are particularly
interested in issue politics rather than
candidate politics so they're active in
tax payer groups in drug policy reform
groups in term limits advocacy things
like that
whose the best-known academic today
that's a libertarian I would say
probably Milton Friedman Richard Epstein
at the University of Chicago Law School
is certainly another Robert Nozick at
Harvard University wrote a book called
Anarchy state and utopia which is very
important which is excerpted in the
libertarian reader I'm not sure if he
calls himself a libertarian these days
Nosek is very interesting guy he writes
a book he gets intensely into a subject
then he moves on to different subjects
so in the 20 years since he wrote
Anarchy state and utopia he hasn't
written about political philosophy he's
written about other things and this
primer that you have the I'm not the
firmer the libertarian reader you have a
lot of different articles in here and
and you have something from the nation
the nation was magazine the nation was a
libertarian magazine in the first half
of its life I believe it was founded
around the time of the civil war and
throughout the 19th century it was a
classical liberal magazine it advocated
free markets the rule
law decolonization international peace
but very much free markets and so
there's an essay they're actually
written in the nation in nineteen
hundred looking back on the 19th century
and saying look at the tremendous
achievements that free people freed from
vexatious meddling of governments have
been able to produce but alas
today it seems that people have
forgotten the principles of the
Declaration of Independence that brought
us to this happy state and we are going
to be doomed to a century of war and
statism before we get back on the path
and that was pretty prescient we have
been through a 20th century with a lot
of war in a lot of statism because we
forgot the principles of the Declaration
of Independence Thomas Paine has a piece
in there I'm a Spain one of the great
libertarians of all time one of the
interesting things about Tom Paine he's
known as a rabble-rousing writer
everybody reads common sense when
they're in college common sense is a
great essay one of the great things
about Thomas Paine is that he put
together two elements of libertarian
theory one is the theory of justice of
individual rights but adult individuals
have the right to live their life the
way they want to the other is a theory
called spontaneous order the theory of
the self-regulating society it's
academics would say it's not the
normative theory it's the positive
theory it observes the world and says if
you leave people alone
to trade and exchange and make their own
decisions a self-regulating order will
emerge you don't need the government to
create order order emerges Thomas Paine
put those two ideas together and so in
that sense he's a really key libertarian
thinker you also have the Declaration
that depends with Thomas Jefferson one
of the greatest pieces of libertarian
writing ever why I think that the I
think it's the second paragraph of the
Declaration we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal that they are endowed by their
creator with certain unalienable rights
that among these are life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness
that is a beautiful succeed eloquent
statement of what libertarianism is and
it goes on to say that it is to secure
these rights that governments are
instituted among men that's
we have government not to give us
midnight basketball not to tuck us in at
night we have government to secure our
rights and that paragraph goes on to say
when any government ceases to do that it
is the right of the people to alter or
abolish it that was where you got from
the libertarian theory to the right to
rebel against an oppressive government
what's Federalist number 10 why did you
include that in the Federalist number 10
talks about the dangers of faction and
how the Constitution was designed to
limit faction we might say special
interest today the Constitution was
designed to keep any of us from being
able to use the government to get what
we want at the expense of other people
that's in a section called skepticism
about power which is the first section
of the libertarian reader and in a sense
the first principle of libertarianism is
as Lord Acton said power tends to
corrupt so libertarians are very
skeptical about anybody having a lot of
power that's why we like federalism
that's why we like separation of powers
within the federal government that in
fact is why libertarianism really arose
in Europe why didn't it happen in Africa
Asia Latin America wherever one reason
is that Europe was a very divided
civilization it has obviously right now
many countries through the Middle Ages
it had more countries and city-states
and polities than it does now and I
think it was the fact of one
civilization divided into so many
different governments that kept any
government from getting so powerful but
it could stamp out the ideas of Liberty
and the expressions of people living
their own lives on page 193 why
government gets too big bureaucrats and
politicians are just as self-interested
as the rest of us you say that require
explanation yeah I think a lot of us
learn in our civics books in college
that you know there are two kinds of
institutions there are the
self-interested profit seeking
institutions of business and then
there's the Public Interest in that's
government but some great think actually
Thomas Jefferson sort of refuted that
200 years ago but more recently James
Buchanan and Gordon Tullock and some of
their college
the public choice school of economics
and politics said wait a minute two
roommates graduate from college one goes
to work for General Motors one goes to
work for the government are we supposed
to believe that starting the day after
college the one who goes to General
Motors is self-interested and the other
one is public interested what if just as
a hypothesis we said people who go into
government are also self-interested like
any normal human being
what would happen if that was the truth
and what they found of course was when
you spell out the implications of that
you you see a government pretty much
like the one we have so the argument
that I'm making there is people in
government are self-interested just like
people in business the question becomes
which kind of institution will serve the
public interest better and I contend and
libertarians contend that in fact
competitive market processes will cause
all of us to serve the public interest
better than coercive government
structures you took you give you some
examples in there and one of the people
you talk about is Dwayne Andres
archers Daniel Midland what would a
libertarian do with that that whole I
don't know what they call it subject but
what would you do to make things
different the ethanol senator Baba's
involvement the best thing to do would
be to take away the government's power
to hand out favors to companies like
Archer Daniels Midland I'm a DM
subsidizes all the politicians in
Washington it subsidizes all the public
affairs shows except yours because you
know on all the commercial networks you
see ads from atm this is all part of a
process because a DM earns its profits
in Washington most companies earn their
profits out in the marketplace a DM
earns most of its profits in Washington
the ethanol subsidy makes it profitable
for them to produce ethanol I believe
they also profit from the sugar quotas
which prevent cheap sugar from overseas
from coming into our country they really
do their farming in Washington and so
what libertarians would like to do is
take away from the federal government
the power to hand out those benefits a
great thing might be if we had a
constitutional amendment that said
Congress shall have no power to regulate
the economy if you did something like
that a DM would have to go out and look
for profits in the marketplace like
other companies
why do you think they spent so much
money on the new shows because I think
it enhances their image in Washington
makes them seem like nice guys and so
when they go in and ask for a hundred
million dollar subsidy not only have
they given money to the politicians but
they've created this image of themselves
as a public spirited company so it
doesn't seem so outrageous do you think
they would get this subsidy if they
didn't send money to the politicians or
you know help finance their campaigns
I certainly hope the politicians
wouldn't do things that crazy for free
but I don't think it's as
straightforward as that might imply
there are lots of subsidies lots of
regulations that benefit some companies
that I think probably nobody has ever
given the contribution for or anything
like that we have a government both
parties Republicans and Democrats
liberals and conservatives who believe
that the role of the federal government
is to divvy up the national product to
decide well we have six trillion dollars
in our economy this year how much will
we let the people who earned it keep and
how much will we give to ADM and how
much will we give to Chrysler and how
much will we give to Social Security how
much will we give to farm subsidies they
don't seem to have an understanding that
that money is earned by individuals and
that the people who earn it really have
a prior claim to it would you think that
Chrysler bailout a number of years ago I
think it was just an absolute
quintessential example of what's wrong
with government subsidies the Chrysler
Corporation couldn't produce cars that
Americans wanted to buy so a great
cartoon ones in fact I think ed green
has it framed on his wall my boss at the
Cato Institute it shows Lee Iacocca in a
car with a bumper sticker that says buy
what America builds good old by American
notion and a guy in a Japanese car
parked next to him with a bumper sticker
that says build what America buys that's
what Chrysler wasn't doing they weren't
building what America buys so they were
going to go out of business so they went
to the government instead of figuring
out a way to produce a car that
Americans wanted to buy they went to the
government they got a one and a half
billion dollar subsidy and a lot of
people think that was a great success we
saved the Chrysler Corporation we did
although of course they downsized by
two-thirds of their workers so we didn't
say very many of the jobs and besides
which what we don't see and this is one
of the key readings in the libertarian
reader is what is not seen that
one-and-a-half billion dollars that was
lent to Chrysler was not lent to you to
build a house was not lent to some other
businessman to expand the business that
was actually selling things people
wanted to buy was not borrowed by a
student to go to college and become a
more productive worker we can't see what
didn't happen but what we do know is
that people who were more creditworthy
didn't get credit because that money
went to the Chrysler Corporation now if
you had to put together a little an
evenings discussion group of
libertarians that you there in their
libertarian readier people that you'd
like to have around the table to hear
their wisdom on libertarianism in the
history that you've known who would you
put this put five or six hundred to
table are you talking about history
forever
or contemporary or five or six people
you'd like to have at your dinner table
to talk about politics and Liberty what
I'd like to have Thomas Jefferson there
George will called him the man of the
millennium because he enunciated really
the the concept of the millennium which
is individual rights so I'd love to have
him there
I'd say Friedrich Hayek who I did have
the pleasure of meeting was a great
Nobel laureate economist and social
thinker but I certainly would like to
have spent more time talking to him
probably Milton Friedman who fortunately
is still alive and I do have a chance to
talk to sometimes and I think probably I
Rand who for all of her foibles was a
brilliant fascinating penetrating woman
and I would love to have been able to
spend some time with her and see what it
was that people found so mesmerizing
personally and maybe I think maybe
that's four maybe I'd take Thomas Paine
Cato is set up how who runs well we have
a board of directors of about a dozen
people and we have contributors about
12,000 people who become Cato sponsors
and support us financially and then we
have 50 staff members the president and
CEO is Ed Crane who founded it I'm the
executive vice president our chairman is
William to scannin who was a top
economic adviser to President Reagan and
then
we have about ten policy directors who
direct our work in the area
constitutional studies fiscal policy
environmental issues and so on
we went who of those do we see on a
regular basis on television shows well I
think you see build a scan determine who
talks about economics a lot Steve Moore
our director of fiscal policy studies
talks a lot about taxes and spending
roger peel on our director of
constitutional studies Jerry Taylor our
director of natural resource studies
those are all pretty visible and I think
Ted carpenter our vice president for
foreign and defense policy studies does
a lot of the defense oriented shows his
good band I'm Doug Mandel yes he's not a
policy director on he's a senior fellow
but he does a lot of writing for us so
you see a lot of Abed's by him and he
does a lot of TV appearances I asked our
folks to put the names of your board
members on the screen so that the
audience can see who supports this how
much let's let's take a look at who they
are there's Peter Ackerman of Rockport
financial limited Kay Tucker Anderson of
Cumberland Associates James Blanchard
the third Jefferson Financial John is it
blocker blocker of Woodside California
Frank Bond of Holliday health spas
Gordon Kane of the Sterling group Edward
crane who is your president Richard
Dennis of the dentist trading group
Theodore Forsman of foresman little and
company is that Ethel Mae Ethel a
Humphries of the tamko asphalt David
Cooke coke I'd get that wrong John
Malone of telecommunications Inc and
William niskanen David Patten of the
patent company Howard rich us turn
lemons and Frederick Smith of the
Federal Express corporation I think one
common thread of the people I mean in
general the people who are on the board
other than the two staff members are
significant financial contributors
people who help us raise money as well
as giving some themselves I think one
common theme running through there is
they're entrepreneurs you don't see very
many presidents of fortune 500
corporations these are people who have
built their own companies they have a
sense of the dynamics of the free market
John Malone really helped to build TCI
the big the big cable company Fred Smith
is probably the best-known
the founder of Federal Express Ted
Forsman is a venture capitalist which
sort of means that he funds
entrepreneurs to get businesses off the
ground and some people here may have
heard of Howard rich who runs us term
limits he is also a businessman an
investor but us term limits has been his
big political interest recently what was
that thing that richard denna's funded a
couple years ago well rich dennis has
funded a lot of things he is a generous
contributor to Cato he is also a funder
of the drug policy foundation he's very
much in favor of reform of our current
policies of drug prohibition he's a
commodities trader in Chicago he's also
an active Democrat so he's funded a lot
of Democrats there's something else he
funded either media organization I can't
remember well if your if your memory
goes way back he funded something called
the Roosevelt Center for American policy
studies I think was the name funded that
quite generously and that organization
is no longer around how many of those
board members are members of political
parties inactive um I don't know I
suppose half of them probably rich
Dennis as I say as an active Democrat I
think Ted Forsman is an active
supply-side Republican a fan of Jack
Kemp and Steve Forbes and people like
that I think probably several of them
are Republicans and a couple of them
have been or are in the Libertarian
Party actually David Koch was the
libertarian party's candidate for Vice
President in 1980 which was you know the
only way you can give a large amount of
money to a minor party turns out there's
all sorts of ways to give a large amount
of money to a major party that we didn't
know about have you ever sat around the
table and listened to those people on
that board talk about politics somewhat
yes sir at our board meeting what's
their number one interest I think their
number one interest I mean I I think
it's broad I think their number one
interest is individual liberty and so
that goes into a lot of areas that's why
they're on Cato's board instead of some
organization that only does one issue
but I suppose if you if you insist on
narrowing it down from the concept that
they really do believe in Liberty I'd
probably say economic growth they're
very concerned about over taxation over
regulation over spending and what that's
doing to the prospects for growth you
know we used to grow at three or four
percent a year in this country it
doesn't sound like much we used to grow
at three or four percent now we grow at
one or two
but it's the difference between doubling
your standard of living in 15 years or
30 years or 70 years and that makes a
big difference and I think that we
shouldn't be growing as fast as we did
in the 1950s we should be growing faster
we have more rapid technological
improvement we have global markets now I
think the fact that we're only growing
at half the rate we were then is
atrocious in your book you talk about
the post office and that as a matter of
fact that you've got Fred Schmidt there
with FedEx you don't think much of the
post office I don't think much of large
gargantuan bureaucratic monopolies
that's right you know we have an
antitrust division we talk all the time
about competition and monopoly and if
two companies merge will that be a
threat to competition and then you've
got this huge part of the economy
communication of ideas and it's run by
an 800,000 person government monopoly
now what's happening of course is that
increasingly all important
communications are going through Federal
Express or UPS or through electronic
mail so even though the Postal Service
has a legal monopoly it's losing a large
part of its market share you have it I
don't know that we can do this another
you have a charter maybe explain it what
Uncle Sam has really promised you latest
official projections available as of
January 1996 and it get real close if
you can on this what was the point of
this the point of it is to say we have a
serious problem looming with Social
Security a lot of people think that
Social Security is the greatest success
of big government and I think that's a
pretty good indication if that's their
greatest success they don't have much to
claim because what's happening with
Social Security is that it was a great
system for older people it's a great
system for people who are retired now
but for baby boomers and for Generation
Xers it's going to be a disaster
we are heading toward bankruptcy around
2010 a lot of people like to say we're
headed toward bankruptcy in 2029 that's
when the theoretical trust fund is
depleted but around 2010 the cash flow
turns negative there's more money going
out than there is coming in and since
the only thing that's in this Social
Security trust fund is government bonds
this is just a matter of they're going
to start cashing in government bonds
which means the US government is going
to have to start subsidizing Social
Security if they didn't have the
government bonds what would happen when
the cash flow turned negative the US
government would have to start funding
Social Security more than what our
Social Security taxes are we have a
looming crisis that politicians don't
want to admit they've created and that
chart has a lot of details on it
what would live returns do about
Medicare I think that we have to move
toward having more of a free market in
health care you know it's easy to say in
theory I don't think the government
should be involved in retirement I don't
think it should be involved in health
care we get better health care we can
save more money for retirement if we
have minimal taxes minimal regulation
and we let the free market work the best
retirement plan we could have would have
been to continue a growth rate of 4%
rather than knock it down to one and a
half percent but it's more difficult
once the government sets up these
programs and you have to get out of them
then it's more difficult we need to move
toward free markets in health care in
the case of Medicare that might mean
voucherizing it it might mean letting
younger people out to invest in private
plans like medical savings accounts it
certainly with Social Security it means
letting younger people out to invest in
private retirement accounts where they
can do better
Medicare is going to be even more
difficult because it's more bankrupt
going to be out of money sooner but I
would say voucherizing marketizing and
putting more reliance on individuals
saving for their own healthcare is the
solution
there's the libertarian reader inside
there you also have an article by HL
Mencken was he a libertarian who was it
he generally was he was probably the
greatest journalist of the first half of
this century
he was interestingly enough known as a
liberal back during the era of Coolidge
and Harding he was you know this great
liberal journalist who was always
railing against the pomposity of the
complacent bourgeoisie of the Republican
administrations then when Roosevelt came
in making started to be considered a
conservative because he also railed
against the excessive government in the
pomposity 's of the New Deal I think
what he really was was a libertarian all
those times he believed in the
individual and he didn't much believe in
government
except this the you have the Federalists
and the anti-federalists and in yearbook
especially the one the libertarian read
here in the introduction is talking
about that James Madison was a
conservative libertarian Federalist and
then a Anti Federalist is a radical
libertarian what was the difference this
is a libertarian country all the
founders were basically libertarians in
an earlier generation we would have
called them liberals or classical
liberals they would have called
themselves Whigs perhaps but we can look
back at their ideas and say they were
basically libertarians they believed in
individual rights they believed in
government only by consent they believed
in free markets and the difference
between the Federalists and
anti-federalists was over issues of how
much power can you give to the federal
government and the Federalists wanted to
give a tiny amount of power to the
federal government and the
anti-federalists thought that even a
tiny amount of power was too much and as
I say in the reader we're still judging
that argument because if you look at
what the Federalists gave the government
in the Constitution it's a pretty
libertarian grant of power the
government was not granted the power to
go out and do everything from Social
Security to midnight basketball it was
granted the power to regulate commerce
between the states and to handle foreign
affairs that was about it
the anti-federalists said you do that
and it will get too powerful it will
exceed its bounds you will not bind down
the government by this Constitution and
clearly on that score you have to say
the anti-federalists were right now
whether that means we should have stuck
with the Articles of Confederation and
not tried the Constitution is a more
difficult question but I think if you
look at George Mason and James Madison
you're talking about two virginia
libertarians who disagreed over whether
the Constitution was too risky
are there any libertarians in the
Supreme Court no I don't think there's
anybody on the Supreme Court that I
would call a libertarian you look at
different you can you can certainly find
I think justice Thomas's opinion in the
Lopez case which said there are things
the federal government can't do was
certainly a libertarian analysis but on
some civil liberties
we've had people who might be considered
more liberal give ringing libertarian
dissents or opinions is Bill Clinton in
all of return Bill Clinton is so
eclectic and has such wide-ranging
interests that it's hard to say Bill
Clinton has been reported recently to
have said he might be interested in
replacing the income tax with the
national sales tax I'm not that keen on
a national sales tax but it would be
better than the federal income tax and
he's also talked about how successful
the privatization of Social Security and
Chile has been so if you look at those
things also I think you can say in some
ways Bill Clinton has a tolerant
libertarian attitude toward social
issues although after Dick Morris got
hold of him and said move to the right
and talk about curfews and school
uniforms and things he might have come
across as less so in your book you also
in one of the two books here by the way
of the one of the libertarian reader
sells for twenty seven fifty and your
premier sells for $23 how many copies of
each did the Free Press print you know I
think there's about 12,000 copies of
each in print which is a fairly small
run for a popular book but we'll see how
popular it is did you is this your first
book I've edited several books for the
Cato Institute the primer is the first
book I've written how did you put all
this together how much help to jail I
had a lot of help from some libertarian
scholars and colleagues I would say that
when I was first asked what about
putting together a reader and I sat down
and made a list of 30 articles I would
put in 25 of those are in there and
another 20 have been added so I was you
know I was 60% right on my first cut but
I asked a lot of people for advice and I
balanced it and I said I'd like to have
that but I really have to cover this
subject so would have to do something
else and and then at the last minute we
decided that the book was about 10% too
long for the price we wanted to put on
it and everything
so some amount of help I think I think
you could say this represents close to a
consensus of what libertarian scholars
these days if they could all vote on
what should be in there should be other
names you have in air our Frederick
Douglass Frederick Douglass and William
Ellery Channing on slavery and William
Lloyd Garrison what
what's your position on slavery and
slavery is about the greatest violation
of individual rights there can be and so
abolitionism was clearly the libertarian
cause of its day William Lloyd Garrison
Frederick Douglass I think we're
libertarians if you read their writings
they talk about individual rights they
talk about no man is empowered to govern
another and they call slavery man
stealing and the reason they call it man
stealing is they're saying you are
trying to steal the very essence of a
man from himself and they rested their
argument on self ownership which is an
old libertarian theory that the first
reading in here about it is from Richard
Overton who was one of the Levellers in
England self ownership the idea that I
own myself that is the base of my
individual rights nobody owns me I don't
belong to the collective I don't belong
to other people I own myself and if I do
slavery is an attempt to steal me from
myself you have a woman as a moral being
by Sarah Grimke that's way pronounced I
think so and the other one is Angelina
Grimke rights and responsibilities of
women what's the point there they were
sisters they were abolitionists in the
struggle for abolitionism they began
thinking about their own rights as women
and realized that they didn't have full
equal rights either and so women did not
do a lot of public writing at that time
they did do public speaking but both of
those excerpts I believe are from
letters now they were letters that were
sort of like open letters to the Boston
anti-slavery society and one of the
reasons they're in there is is partly
because feminism and abolitionism were
clearly libertarian causes but another
reason is that both of those wrest the
case for abolitionism and women's rights
squarely on the notion that each adult
individual holds moral responsibility
for his own actions and so to try to
control his actions either to make him a
slave or to forbid him from entering
into contracts which was a way women
were treated at the time is to take away
that moral responsibility to tell him
you can't do your to tell her you can't
be a full and complete adult because you
don't have the responsibility to to
enter into actions and be responsible
for them
you mentioned Lord Acton earlier and you
quoted him on power is it does it mean
anything that most people when you they
tend to quote him they I'm looking for
the quote here people say power corrupts
and absolute power corrupts absolutely
and then some people who know the quote
come back and say power tends to corrupt
that's right power tends to corrupt and
always corrupt in here from what you say
well I guess I would say it always tends
to corrupt it's always dangerous but
this is the tension in setting up a
government we need a government of some
minimal sort to protect us from each
other most people want to live their
lives peacefully most of the time but
some people would harm other people if
they had the chance that's why we set up
a government to protect our peaceful
exercise of our rights but then we
immediately face the dilemma how much
power can you give the government
without it starting to infringe on your
rights and that's why I think you say
power tends to corrupt if you look at
the United States we've had 200 years of
a pretty free society power has not
entirely corrupted the people who have
run the United States but it has tended
to move in that direction and I don't
mean just the john hwang illegal
fundraising and all that kind of thing i
mean the notion that politicians are
better than the rest of us that they
deserve better protection that they are
treated almost as if they were monarchs
we have this inauguration you know it's
going to be the most expensive
inauguration ever the most expensive
public funds anyway for a guy who's
already president in England that's what
you do when you crown a king not when
you have a new prime minister so I think
there's a sense that we have too much of
the trappings of power associated even
with our Republican form of government
you point out to us that Lord Acton's
real name is John Emmerich Edward
Dahlberg Acton who was he well he was a
very distinguished nineteenth-century
British scholar reader he's kind of a
sad case because he was always going to
write the history of Liberty in the
world and it would have been a brilliant
book it's it said that he read a book a
day for his entire life and he wrote a
book review a day for much of it and he
wrote essays and he lectured it I
believe was Oxford University but he
never wrote that book and libertarians
call it the greatest book never written
you say that a person named Boyd childs
jr. is one of the brightest and most
dazzling personalities I've ever known
and remains an inspiration to me and
many other libertarians well to be
technical that line is actually written
by Tom Palmer who wrote the
bibliographical essay for that book but
I endorse it you know did you know him
yes I knew Roy childs very well he was
another person who kind of sadly never
wrote a book he would have been a few
years older than I am he would be in his
40s now and he died young but he was a
brilliant a thinker and writer
fascinating person bubbling over with
ideas I always say he once made me
fascinated by Opera for about ten
minutes I don't know anything about
opera but I just asked him a question
once and he started rattling on about it
and it was fascinating and and he had
that capacity he wrote a lot of
libertarian essays which unfortunately
never became a book John Perry Barlow is
a rancher of former lyricist for the
Grateful Dead and a co-founder of the
Atlantic Electronic Frontier Foundation
why is his essay in it well he has an
essay called the future of government
and it helps us to get into the you know
this this goes all the way back to the
Bible and through the American
Revolution but I wanted to get into the
Information Age and John Perry Barlow I
think has the last essay in the book
it's called the future of government and
it talks about how the Information Age
is really going to undermine the powers
of government makes it possible for
people to get more information and they
ever had available to them makes it
possible for them to live outside the
bounds of any particular government
we're going to see people in the next
few decades moving to wherever the taxes
are lowest and the living is best it's
going to be very difficult for
governments to control people because
we're going to have so much freedom to
move around because we're spending so
much time with this gentleman this year
I see a number of essays in here by
Alexis de Tocqueville why was he a
libertarian Tocqueville was a
libertarian one that you might call a
conservative libertarian very concerned
about tradition and order in society
something of an aristocratic approach
why do the liberals claim
- well I don't think there's a you mean
today's modern liberal I can't imagine I
really don't know what they think they
see in de Tocqueville Tocqueville was a
brilliant critic of American democracy
was great admirer of it but he pointed
out the kinds of things that could
happen could be foibles of a Democratic
Society which was a new experiment
people didn't know he was really kind of
predicting there's an essay in there of
what sort of despotism democratic
nations have to fear we know what sort
of despotism non democratic nations had
could there be despotism in a democratic
nation and he warned about a government
that would beneficent lis cover the the
surface of society with Manute and Teddy
rules and regulations and I have to say
that was pretty precious I mean today
we've got regulations on everything from
how long you have to stay in the
hospital after you have a baby to
midnight basketball to what drugs you
can take if you're sick and your doctor
recommends something the FDA doesn't all
for our own good the government is
always beneficent to us and yet they're
covering our society with this network
of rules if you had to pick a book or
two that besides your book right here
that you would want to read that would
be you know the best thought for you and
libertarianism what would that be um I
would probably say two books by
Friedrich Hayek's the Road to Serfdom
which is a relatively popular
introduction to libertarian liberal
ideas and the constitution of Liberty
which is more his magnum opus and I just
I kept reading and underlining the
constitution of Liberty in particular as
I was writing these books and I wanted
to include every chapter from it in the
libertarian reader when did he die um he
died in 1992 he was about 90 years old
what do you remember about him well
personally of course when I met him he
was a very old man and so I remember a
very old man of old fashioned European
demeanor a gracious gentleman scholar
who was always so careful and precise to
state his objections to other people's
ideas without ever criticizing other
people personally he dedicated his book
the Road to Serfdom to the Socialists of
all parties and I think he was very
sincere and wanting to say I share your
aspirations I
than your dreams but please read this
warning of what will happen if you let
government have too much power and he
kept that respect for every for all of
his adversaries to the end of his life
when he died where was he but I believe
you know he had gone back to I believe
he was a native of Austria and he had
gone back to Germany where obviously
they speak German and so I think he felt
more comfortable after spending about 30
years in England in the United States
here are the two books first time we've
done this
the first one is libertarianism a primer
by David Bose and the one right under
that is the libertarian reader also
edited by David Vaz which includes a lot
of contemporary and classic writings
about libertarianism thank you very much
for your time thank you